we have already seen a situation
multiple times where there is some
parameter associated with a population
maybe it's the proportion of a
population that supports a candidate
maybe it's the mean of a population the
mean height of all the people in the
city and we've determined that it's
unpractical or we just there's no way
for us to know the true population
parameter but we could try to estimate
it by taking a sample size so we take n
samples and then we calculate a
statistic based on that we've also seen
that not only can we calculate the
statistic which is trying to estimate
this parameter but we can construct a
confidence interval about that statistic
based on some confidence level and so
that confidence that confidence interval
would look something like this it would
be the value of the statistic that we
have just calculated plus or minus some
margin of error and so we'll often say
this critical value Z and this will be
based on the number of standard
deviations we want to go above and below
that statistic and so then we'll
multiply that times the standard
deviation of the sampling distribution
for that statistic now what we'll see is
we often don't know this to know this
you oftentimes even need to know this
parameter for example in the situation
where the parameter that we're trying to
estimate and construct confidence
intervals for is say the population
proportion what percentage of the
population supports a certain candidate
well in that world the statistic is the
sample proportion so we would have the
sample proportion plus or minus Z star
times well we can't calculate this
unless we know the population proportion
so instead we estimate this with the
standard error of the statistic which in
this case is P hat times 1 minus P hat
the sample proportion times 1 minus the
sample proportion over our sample size
if the parameter we're trying to
estimate is the population mean then our
statistic is going to be the sample mean
so in that scenario we are going to be
looking at our statistic is our sample
mean plus or minus Z star now if we knew
the standard deviation of this
population we would know what the
standard deviation of the sample
distribution of our statistic is it
would be equal to the standard deviation
of our population times the square root
of our sample size but we often will not
know this in fact it's very unusual to
know this and so sometimes you will say
okay if we don't know this let's just
figure out the sample standard deviation
of our sample here so instead we'll say
okay let's take our sample mean plus or
minus Z 2 star times the sample standard
deviation of our sample which we can
calculate divided by the square root of
n now this might seem pretty good if
we're trying to construct a confidence
interval for our sample for our mean but
it turns out that this is not not so
good because it turns out that this
right over here is going to actually
underestimate the actual interval the
true margin of error you need for your
confidence level and so that's why
statisticians have invented another
statistic instead of using Z they call
it T instead of using AZ table they use
a T table and we're going to see this in
future videos and so if you are actually
trying to construct a confidence
interval for a sample mean and you don't
know the true standard deviation of a
population which is normally the case
instead of doing this what we're going
to do is we're gonna take our sample
mean plus or minus and our critical
value we'll call that T star times our
sample standard deviation which we can
calculate divided by the square root of
N and so the real functional difference
is that this actually is going to give
us the confidence interval that actually
has the level of confidence that we want
if we have one a 95% level of confidence
if we keep compute if we keep computing
this over and over again for multiple
samples that roughly 95% of the time
this interval will contain our true
population mean and to functionally do
it and we'll do it in future videos you
really just have to look up a T table
instead of a Z table